in the last video I talked about the
Google neurogenic steps and then I said
that in the next video I would talk
about the allosteric regulation of the
enzymes that catalyze those steps but
before I get to that I want to mention a
few little things about writing out the
steps for glycolysis and gluconeogenesis
if you're asked or if you're told to
draw out the step catalyzed by
hexokinase why no the exo kinase is the
first reaction of glycolysis we already
take a glucose to Google 6 phosphate we
invest in ATP and this happens now I
know that this this enzyme only exists
in glycolysis it does not have anything
to do with gluconeogenesis so if I'm
told to draw the step catalyzed by EXO
kinase I know it's this because it's
step is irreversible and it's the only
thing that EXO kinase will catalyze
likewise if I'm told to draw the step
catalyzed by Google 6 phosphatase then I
know that I'm going from G 6p to glucose
I'm adding water getting a phosphate out
and that's the only step that Google six
phosphatase is going to catalyze and I
know this step is specific to
gluconeogenesis and it's only in
Wallonia genesis but what if I'm told to
draw this step catalyzed by enol ace
well then then I get confused because I
know that enol ace is one of those
enzymes that cattle can catalyze both
the forward and the reverse reaction so
this is an irreversible step what you
mean not reversible sorry reversible
this is a reversible step so I don't
know what they're asking for are they
asking for the reaction in which we go
from 2-phosphoglycerate to
phosphoenolpyruvate or are they asking
for the reaction in which we go in
fossil you know pyruvate 2
2-phosphoglycerate so there's ambiguity
if you're told to just draw the step
catalyzed by you know lace that's not
enough information you need to know
whether you're being asked for the
glycolytic or gluconeogenic step
that's an important piece of information
because if I know they're asking for the
step from Whitehall Isis then I know
it's this one the forward reaction right
going from 2-phosphoglycerate to fossil
in a pyruvate which we can convert to
pyruvate which would be of course the
glycolysis pathway but if I'm going from
phosphoenolpyruvate to to
phosphoglycerate then that's the
gluconeogenesis reaction right going the
other way
so if you're told to write the step
catalyzed by a particular enzyme that
you know is reversible then you have to
know whether you're asked to draw the
glycolytic or gluconeogenic step but for
other ones other reactions in which are
that catalyze irreversible steps then
there doesn't need to be a particular
specification because you know you
should know that that step is
irreversible and therefore can only be
part of one particular pathway so I just
wanted to mention this as a sort of
heads-up and it's something to be aware
of thanks for watching